Speaker 1: Last Friday, we got the new consumer
price index data and we found out that the
inflation rate year over year for the month of May
was 8.6%. There was this idea before the numbers
were released that maybe inflation had peaked
over the past couple of months and we'd start to
head down a little bit. But this new data release
really throws a wrench into that theory because
we're still trending upwards, albeit slightly. In
March, we were at 8.5% year over year inflation.
In April, we declined modestly to 8.3%.
And in May, once again, we went up to 8.6%.
It was predicted by economists ahead of the CPI
data release that inflation would go down to about
8.2%. So instead of being slightly down, we're
heading slightly up. The Consumer Price Index,
or CPI is a broad assessment of prices in the
economy, including everything from food to fuel to
housing to discretionary products. The main reason
for the CPI increase appears to be that gas prices
have gone up quite significantly over the past
month or so. Gas prices due to pent up demand in
the economy, given the recovery from the pandemic
and due to Russia's invasion of Ukraine and other
factors continue to go up, they just reached a
record $5 a gallon and it's likely a trend that's
going to continue all summer long because we know
that gas prices tend to go up with demand during
the summer months. And certainly the situation
in Russia and Ukraine has not settled down.
So we may see $6 a gallon gasoline relatively
soon. Who knows? So it's going to be difficult,
of course, to have CPI data going down when
you have gas prices going up so significantly.
If you're going to do that, you really have to
make up for it in the other categories that it
assesses. And we just did not do nearly enough
to make up for it. Interestingly enough, though,
core inflation, which removes food and energy
from the index is at 6% for the month of May year
over year, whereas in April is at 6.2%. So that's
positive. That's heading in the right direction.
But some people will say, well, you can't just
really take out energy and food costs from the
equation, given that they're such an important
metric of what takes place in the economy. The
CPI release caused the markets to tumble quite
a bit at the end of last week. On Thursday and
Friday we saw the major indices drop about three
4%. And the reason is that high inflation means
that the Federal Reserve is probably going
to have to be more hawkish when it comes to
raising interest rates, how often they're going
to raise the interest rates and by how much?
Because the idea is if you have high inflation,
you have to cool down the economy to encourage
less spending. And that means that companies
won't be able to make as much profit, which
means that investors won't make as much money,
which means that people often will sell off.
Aside from raising the interest rates, which is
really under the purview of the Federal Reserve,
there's not much that the Biden administration
can do when it comes to inflation and gas prices.
That's just the sad reality in all of this. When
it comes to gas prices. We know that he can take
more out from the Strategic Petroleum Reserve, but
that maybe will save you $0.10 here, $0.20 here.
It's not going to be enough to significantly drive
costs down. And we also know that the Strategic
Petroleum Reserve really is meant for emergencies.
So if there was a serious emergency that came our
way and we had just released a bunch of oil and
gas, that may not be the best thing to do. Just
about every country we know is dealing with the
high gas prices and the high inflation. So for
me personally, I have a tough time blaming Joe
Biden for this. The people who think that Trump
and Republicans would do better. I'd like
to hear how they would go about doing that.
I think there's just a sentiment of, well, with
Donald Trump and the Republicans were in charge.
We didn't have high inflation, we didn't have gas
prices. So clearly, if we put them back in charge,
they'd be able to get a handle on it. But that's
really just not how it works. Unfortunately, the
average voter doesn't know about that. They don't
know that presidents have very little control over
inflation and gas prices. So it's going to
be tough to communicate that to the American
people ahead of the midterms, especially when
these really are kitchen table issues. Can we
afford gas? Can we afford these other things?
Because prices everywhere are going up. So
it's a big challenge for Democrats heading into
the midterms. We definitely want to focus on gun
control and abortion because we're thinking more
and more. Those could be winning issues for us in
November. We also have to effectively
address how we're going to try to get
a handle on inflation and gas prices, even
if it's just doing whatever we can. Right,
to make some sort of effort to appeal to
people to vote for us again. So that's. The
latest. When it comes to inflation, gas prices
doesn't seem like we have it under control yet.